but now talking about Lu being abroad
for Christmas is it in Dublin will you
discover if there's a Christmas
tradition yeah this yeah there's a
shopping center in Dublin where they put
the Christmas scene out put the nativity
scene out and then they add another
character I think I don't know if it's
like it's must be like it Advent things
Julian okay move move
it's the nativity they are different
days of yeah no they actually first
asked the wise men of moving towards
there's a thing there's no room he'll
just be your full Star Wars but yes shop
and I'm walking through the shop I'm on
to I kind of bored I'm just wandering
around killing time and I see this very
sparse nativity scene and and I look in
it and in the perspex finishes there I
think right so I go into a shop and I
thought you know other shops that sell
knickknacks for Nana's you know the like
alt figurines
so I bought a meerkat PC so so there's
the figures and there's a myth and he
was looking like that we've got a
picture of the thing
[Applause]
that looks far more invested in the
whole
bring a gift for about two hours just
watching people walking partnership at
one point the meerkats look because it
was not very firm underfoot at one point
the meerkat slowly started to lean
towards Jesus and I genuinely thought
was a Christmas miracle meerkat starts
moving so I walked over to stand it up
and just as I put my hand in the
security guards or me anyway cheers out
of the shot and said no no I never got
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you